hello everyone thanks for joining us for
Cle and second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development my name is Viviana Campo
psycho and the editor in chief of CNN
and vice president of CNN Media Group
and I am delighted to introduce you to
our next speaker professor Christina
white from University of Illinois
professor white was born in Athens
Greece she received a BA in biochemistry
with highest honors from Smith College
working with with the Stewart Rosenfeld
after a one-year stint in the biology
graduate program working with Christian
and phonemic she received her PhD degree
from Johns Hopkins University in
chemistry with Garry Posner as an ACS
medicinal chemistry pre doctoral fellow
she conducted four postdoctoral studies
at Harvard University with Eric Jacobson
as an NIH postdoctoral fellow and is
currently a professor of chemistry at
the University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign dr. Kristina sorry
professor Kristina white will be
presenting a talk entitled the
functionalisation of carbon hydrogen
bonds
I'll be back to mother a Q&A session
immediately following the presentation
but we will welcome your questions at
any time you only need to click the
green Q&A button in the left corner of
your screen if you need any technical
assistance during the presentation you
can click on the support button located
on the top right hand corner of your
screen please note that CNN does not
endorse any company's products or
services that may be mentioned in this
presentation
finally this talk will be archived and
available on-demand at the conference
website for three months after the live
event broadcasts which will take place
well until December the 16th 2015 we did
without further ado I would like to hang
over to Professor white
all right thank you all for joining me
today I'm going to be talking to you
today about the functionalisation of
very high energy high bond dissociation
energy non-acidic CH bond in complex
molecule settings to form oxygen
nitrogen and carbon carbon bonds with
predictable and high levels of
selectivity why would we want to do such
reactions when consider how organic
chemists traditionally install oxidized
functionality they typically take pre
oxidize starting materials and through
functional human if you lations convert
them to other functionality often nature
does it in different ways nature relies
heavily on both allylic and aliphatic CH
oxidations
here I show the two Ark typical examples
from nature where in one case a
hydrocarbon core is taken and fully
oxidized each one of the most powerful
chemotherapeutics of our time another
where a partially oxidized cores taken
and chemo and site selectively
hydroxylated leading to a very powerful
antimicrobial this last example
highlighted for us early on the idea of
late stage oxidation being able to take
a compound and a very late stage
introduce oxidized functionality this
enables you to divert protecting and D
protecting group strategies and
oxidation state changes that you would
normally have to do through functional
group transformations the bar however
for doing such reactivity is very high
the reactions must be separative meaning
that you're going to have to be able to
put in one equivalent of a molecule and
yet out synthetically useful amounts of
mono oxidized product the reaction
should be predictable particularly in
complex molecule settings and the
reaction unlike what nature does should
be general meaning that you'd like to be
able to do it on beyond just this
topology and functional group array
early on people considered this and it
was very attractive from the standpoint
that
oxidizing molecules can dramatically
change their physical and biological
properties for example it can change the
way a compound is perceived by us with
respect to smell with respect to flavor
and perhaps even most significantly with
respect to biological activity the
addition of hydroxyl groups can
transform something that is biologically
inactive to something that is
biologically active how are people
thinking about doing these types of
oxidations early on they were thinking
about it with respect to hydroxyl
radical and other types of radical
chemistry so for example in the classic
allylic oxidation the koresh oxidation a
tert-butoxide radical is what pleads the
CH bond
unfortunately because it's a free
radical you have no control over which
of these allylic CH bonds becomes
cleaved leading to mixtures of products
with respect to aliphatic CH oxidations
the Jeep's system demonstrates what
happens when you use primarily hydroxide
radicals to affect functionalization you
can see here a two-to-one selectivity of
tertiary relative to secondary
hydroxylation and functionalisation
products now it turns out that depending
on what radical type you use you can
achieve higher levels of tertiary the
secondary selectivity however this
highlights another important fact that
free radical chemistry which is when you
form long-lived carbon centred radicals
you can end up doing other types of
functionalisation with the radical
giving other types of products such as
products with reactive components in
your reaction mixture additionally one
radical can lead to different types of
radicals that can give diverse cell
activities this leads to overall Horsell
activities and also very poor yields and
the reaction mixtures so very early on
our approach for CH activation was to go
through metal metal bound intermediates
for both CH cleavage and the
functionalisation steps and we aim to go
either through high energy metal
oxidants such as the ones used
nature like iron auxins or we aim to go
through other types of intermediates
such as metal carbon intermediate with
some type of functionalisation region
this is orthogonal to nature's approach
which typically selects for the more
electron rich siegbahn organometallic
intermediates generally select for the
less sterically hindered CH bond this
historically was one of the original
ways that you were able to do situ
functionalisation under catalytic
conditions and under preparatory useful
yields you can see here at this example
highlight something very interesting
which is that if you now take the
substrate and make it into a ligand for
the metal you can both control the
reactivity of the reaction and also
control the site selectivity so this
approach has been one that has been
highly used most recently by by workers
to be able to do directive CH
functionalisation however we were
interested in exploiting these very
important organometallic intermediates
however doing so in a much more general
way and so we looked for innate types of
reactivity and main types of
functionality that could lead to these
powerful organometallic Euler medians
and so we were drawn to terminal orphans
as one of these types of functionalities
terminal olefins are in fact eliquid as'
they're very easily appended onto
complex molecules through very powerful
asymmetric reactions such as asymmetric
alkylation reactions we discovered this
catalyst which is broadly available
which does something very special it
enables you now to divert oxidation of
the olefin which is typically what
happens with palladium salts and rather
to do we had a little cleavage of a very
non acidic a little Exige bond to form
very powerful organometallic
intermediates these palladium pile
intermediate with this we identified
ways to be able to affect
functionalisation catalytically we aim
to look at functionalisation reagents
that are in set and ascend
protonated nucleophiles and can be
thought of as weak acids these can be
activated to functionalize and sit you
by using bulky bronsted bases a more
general strategy to promote
functionalization however is to use now
agents that are able to promote
generating a highly electrophilic alien
pile intermediate and so things like pi
acids of depends upon own in combination
with catalytic Lewis acids and often
catalytic Ronstadt acids can promote
functionalisation with this were able to
effect a range of alula clarifications
linear local certifications branch the
load of certifications even macro
lactone formations we can use fairly
acidic nitrogen nucleophiles to also
affect linear Allura combinations and
branch Deluca emanations to form one two
amino alcohol and one three amino
alcohol motifs most recently with the
blondes that acid catalysis we've been
able to flip this tether to form the
regio isomer of these amino alcohol
motifs and we've been able to also
affect direct allylic alkylation
reactions others have shown that you can
very elegantly also do carbon hydrogen
to carbon fluorine bond formation most
recently we found that this PK
requirement is not as strict as we
thought in fact alcohols that have P K's
between 11 and 16 can also be used with
the caveat that they must be able to
coordinate the Palladium and become
acidified at the Palladium Center and
undergo a reductive elimination at that
Center however within this restraint
were able to now afford chrome Ann's
isoko Mane's and even PI R and types of
motifs now what happens if you eliminate
the alcohol altogether from this
reaction mixture what happens is that
you get dehydrogenation reaction is
happening to form reactive butadiene
these can be trapped with complexity
generating reactions such as fields all
the reactions taking a very
topologically simple compound to
something much more Kappa logically
complex
so with these reactions of hand were now
in a position to be able to test this
hypothesis that can streamline synthesis
by introducing oxygen very late into the
synthetic sequence and we can diversify
complex molecules the first example of a
late-stage oxidation was in 2005 when we
looked at his miss oxygenated
intermediate towards my ally here at the
standard way to make this molecule is to
take of this oxygenated precursor block
one end install the allylic alcohol
unblocked this end and now install the
anti-alcohol fragment this is very
reliable chemistry but we're having to
use seven functional group manipulations
you can cut five of those functional
group manipulations out significantly
shortening the sequence by simply going
to a mono oxygenated precursor where you
can directly install your anti-alcohol
fragment completely ignoring Golic
hydrogen there and at a very late stage
install the trans allured alcohol this
cut five steps out of the synthetic
sequence by doing this now if this works
for oxygen it also of course works for
nitrogen which often goes through oxygen
intermediates to be installed here we
show this in the synthesis of a deoxy
mega myosin analogue the traditional
route starts with a fully oxygenated
intermediate and does a series of
functional group transformations to
install the nitrogen we can cut out five
of those functional heat manipulations
and most recently nearly triple the
overall yield of the reaction by simply
directly installing the nitrogen from
this partially oxidized starting
material this also of course works for
carbon and what we found is that this
bissell oxide catalyst is uniquely
effective at being a general catalyst
for promoting direct allylic suite
alkylations
you can see both the doubly activated
eluate substrates and unactivated
allylic substrates where the unactivated
allylic substrate we found that you have
to use larger quantities of monodentate
DMSO self oxide in order to promote
functionalisation
from what we believed to be a cationic
intermediate at very high concentrations
of DMSO an equilibrium occurs where now
we have palladium DMSO is a dominant
species in the reaction that is not as
effective for doing a little CH cleavage
for these unactivated Allu exceeds bonds
therefore we made a switch in the
catalyst going from phenol to benzyl and
now this we believe shifts the
equilibrium back to the Bristol Fox side
palladium which is the most effective
catalyst for the allylic suit cleavage
this now enables us to do some pretty
difficult functionalisation such as
functionalization x' with these tertiary
nucleophiles where we can now bring in
latent functionality and for example
effective intramolecular diels alder
reaction to form a very important type
of core found in the gambino alkaloids
with really good yields and excellent
levels of dietary selectivity this
chemistry and the strategy holds up even
in very late stage types of
manipulations so for example in the
synthesis of year with room Ison's in
over 30 years of some groundbreaking
synthesis of this molecule all the
approaches have had in common a reach
state a solution based Mackrell
activation of a fully oxidized linear
precursor what we're able to do now with
this chemistry is at a very late stage
step 19 of a 22 step synthesis effect
they see oxidation followed by a
concomitant macro activation to form now
this very important c-13 oxygen bond of
the 6-deoxyerythronolide b core with
good yield and excellent diaster
selectivities favoring the natural
diastereomer and this leads to one of
the most efficient synthesis of 60 ox
arizona lead heated date and a good part
of that efficiency has to be credited to
the ability now to install this oxygen
at a very late stage unlike the
classical approaches which typically
install it very early on and have to
carry it throughout the synthesis I'm
going to switch gears now and talk to
you about our program insight
like an aliphatic seat oxidation I put
up this quote to show you how leaders in
this field were thinking about this
problem as recently as 2007 and you can
see here what it says is that there's
very little difference in reactivity
between the various CH bond and alkanes
so targeting a specific CH bond is
difficult this quote is very appropriate
if you look at the literature precedent
at the time in both emanations
hydroxylation alkylations and halogen
ations you can see one overriding factor
is that in all cases these reactions are
not preparatory useful they're using
solvent quantities of substrate and
getting less than 1% yield of substrate
out the other striking component of
these reactions is that there they can
be moderately to highly selective based
on certain factors and so you can see
here that in some cases with the
hydroxylation you can get modest
selectivities with respect to site
selectivity perhaps based on polar
effects for Howard generations the
selectivity can be quite substantial
based on what's believed to be an
inductively with wrong effect of this
this electron withdrawing ester group or
alkylations you can get selectivities
perhaps based on sterics however once
again were struck by the fact that these
selectivities are not synthetically
useful and the reason they're not
synthetically useful is that these
reactions are taken to very low
conversions and only with these very low
conversions are we able to observe and
see these very reasonable site
selectivities and the reason for that is
the reactivity selectivity sort of
paradigm where reactivity oftentimes is
considered to be inversely correlated to
selectivity and so for this reason this
idea that being able to target a
specific seat on with both synthetically
useful reactivity and good site
selectivity is not possible with a very
valid idea as recently as 2007 and so
really what people try to do was to
mimic nature and the way that nature did
this is to create a shape or functional
group recognition cavity
very the highly reactive oxidant within
this cavity and only allowed exposure of
one CH bond at a time to this iron oxide
oily and so by doing this you're able to
in some cases get good selectivity and
this led to some very elaborate very
beautiful but unfortunately not
synthetically useful catalyst designs
that were not general and did not lead
to pepper liberal useful yields of mono
oxygenated products and so when we
started in this area we thought about
the problem very differently we thought
about it with respect to what we have
learned some polyolefin oxidations which
is that if you have a highly
electrophilic bulky catalyst you can
select for the site of oxidation based
on for example the electronics of the
double bond if you have highly electron
rich double bonds you can select for
that site if you have two sites that are
electronically distinguishable but
spherically differentiated with a bulky
catalyst you can distinguish between
them and then you can use very very
subtle effects within the molecules such
as scary electronics and directing
groups to either support or override
these electronic and steric effects and
so our hypothesis was that if we could
identify a catalyst that was both highly
reactive but yet could be sensitive to
these physical organic parameters for
oxidation that we could achieve
predictable and high levels of
reactivity and oxidation after much
experimentation we discovered at least
one of these catalysts which we now call
iron pipi and it's commercially
available this catalysts for the first
time enables you to taking out one
equivalent of substrate and convert it
to hydroxylated product and
synthetically useful notes in addition
to the catalyst structure being very
significant for this reaction the other
significant component is this carboxylic
acid additive were inspired to include
this because non heme iron enzymes in
nature in fact you use carboxylate rich
cores and we'll get to what you believe
this is doing in a minute so we believe
one of the keys
for the reactivity and selectivity of
this system is the ability with this
ligand to divert unselected hydroxide
radical chemistry and to promote very
selectively iron oxide Hema stream where
through the ligand and perhaps even
through the metal we can tune this
reactivity of the metal oXXO tuning it
from being fully concerted auxin would
like to being radical lighten and
stepwise additionally with this ligand
framework were able to to now the
trajectory by which the CH bond attacks
the iron oxy and this can have as you'll
see very profound influences on what
types of Ch bonds are likely to see the
iron oxy in catalyst design so we
believe the mechanism of this reaction
is very biomimetic physical organic
Studies but done by us and mechanistic
and spectroscopic studies done by Larry
Kay indicate that the hydrogen peroxide
and carboxylic acid come together to
form an iron oxide carboxylate spelling
water this now abstract a hydrogen to
form a very short-lived carbon centered
radical that then rebounds to form
hydroxylated product in thinking about
this first step you have strong evidence
to suggest that is going through a metal
bound oxidant for example if you look at
the site selectivities here they're not
based on bond dissociation energy so you
can see a greater than ninety ninety-one
selectivity for hydroxyl aiding at the
stronger slightly stronger CH bond that
is furthest from this electron
withdrawing group and you can see here
again
prepered of li useful yield achieved so
the first time in shown that in fact you
can achieve preparatory useful site
selectivities based on these electronic
effects and within bonds that have very
comparable bond dissociation energies
additionally you see that this reaction
is insensitive to the exposure of oxygen
to the reaction conditions indicating
that this carbon centred radical is not
very long-lived it's not react with
molecular oxygen
additionally cyclohexane each under
hydroxide radical conditions
one with oxidized products under art
conditions needs to only epoxy
information now let's examine the second
step the functionalization this also he
believed is intimately tied to the to
the metal you can see her that the
reaction is completely stereo retentive
meaning that this radical does not exist
even long enough for a bond rotation to
occur
additionally very rapid radical clocks
do not show any indication of ring
opening so let's look now at these
different parameters that we had
outlined before that you would like to
achieve selectivity on if if you're able
to develop such a center catalyst so
with respect to electronics in over
twenty examples that we've examined that
both secondary and tertiary seat
hydroxylation z-- we've observed in all
cases preferential oxidation based on
electronic factors away from the
electron with flying group and you can
see here again always in under
preparatory useful conditions with iron
PP when you have two sites that are
electronically pretty well matched you
do select for the site and is the more
sterically exposed here you can see
again preparatory use for yield eleven
to one selectivity in cases where
there's going to be alleviation of ring
strain in the transition state for the
oxidation iron PP which goes through we
believe a slightly sp2 hybridized
radical intermediate will select for
that site that will alleviate the ring
strain and then finally in cases where
you have a proximal carboxylic acid you
can override very significant steric and
electronic effects that disfavor
oxidation at that site by simply having
a carboxylic acid in your molecule so
you can see here with the methyl ester
we get very poor reactivity but when we
remove the acetic acid from the reaction
mixture we restore reactivity to fifty
percent iron PD P works best when all of
these factors in the molecule are
pointing towards one site iron PP is
pretty equally waste Eric's stereo
tronics and electronic factors within a
molecule so let's go through a simple
sample of this in this man all this
simple chirping derivative we can look
first at electronics and see the
electronics are deactivated side chain
as well as the b-wing of this trans
defilade core we next consider stereo
like next consider sterics and observe
that the squat Center is going to
slightly sterically deactivate both the
C 3 position and also this tertiary site
it additionally is axial and very
sterically hindered and in finally
stereo electronic considerations tell us
that C 2 which is going to benefit from
alleviation of ring strain of 1 3 the
axial ring strain in the transition
state may be favored so again all the
factors in this molecule are pointing
towards C to oxidation there are nine
possible sites of oxidation in this
molecule how will we get preferential
oxidation at the C 2 position once again
one equivalent of substrate preparatory
useful yields there's nothing special
about this trans decalin core we can see
other very topologically distinct
molecules such as this plural newland
derivative again i've outlined for you
all the factors here electronics sterics
in red and stirrer electronics in green
are pointing towards since seven
oxidation there are now 12 possible
sites of oxidation in this molecule and
again preferential oxidation 62% yield
at C 7 just to point out again this is
not based on bond dissociation energies
there are in fact much weaker bonds in
this molecule that do not get oxidized
so you showed with iron PP the first
examples of this concept of late-stage
functionalization on some very complex
biologically interesting molecules such
as artemisinin gibberellic acid which
proceed and really excellent notes very
comparable to what is obtained with p450
systems so the question now becomes what
if with iron PP i'm selecting for one
site what if I want to divert to a
different site so we looked at this
taxes and derivative which was
preferentially oxidized at the c1
position this leads to a carbon center
radical that wrap
rearranges to this other tertiary
radical that we combines to form more
taxing a very very common type of
natural product synthesized along with
tax all in the biosynthesis if we now
take this methyl ester and convert it to
a carboxylic acid in fact divert
oxidation away from c1 we see no
intermolecular c2 oxidation and I've
heard it entirely to c2 to form now to
picture a lactone in a good isolated
yield however what happens if you have
no carboxylic acids in your molecule
which is often the case this really
highlights the restrictive nature of
having to use a directing group to
achieve site selectivity for c2
oxidation let's take for example
artemisinin birth iron PEP
and natural people with the enzymes
oxidize selectively at the c10 position
what if alternatively you'd like to
oxidize at the c9 position well then we
would have to either do a de novo
synthesis or we have to evolve a p450 to
divert oxidation at the c9 position and
that was done however what if you'd like
to be able to divert this oxidation with
a small molecule catalyst and we'd like
to do it in a very general sense so we'd
like to do it not just for topologies
and functional group or ways that are
like artemisinin but for other types of
small molecules we consider this
challenge and we thought about now
thinking about the second way that iron
PP achieves selectivity which is this
approach trajectory of the CH bond and
we questioned what would happen if you
simply shrunk this approach directory in
half by now making the CF 3 PP
modification if you did this now CH
bonds that are very sterically hindered
would most likely not see the iron oxide
as readily as c CH bonds that are less
sterically hindered and this also
highlights the big difference between
this iron oxide type of oxidation and c
radical oxidation this were a hydroxide
radical the functionalisation would be
diffusion controlled as soon as it bumps
into it you get functionalisation here
thus each bond has to achieve just the
right stereo electronic alignment in
order for reactivity to happen meaning
that seach bonds must hit many times the
iron off so before a reaction can occur
and this now by shrinking the trajectory
will make left more sterically hindered
seeds bonds less likely less likely to
hit the iron Aqsa so with this
modification we looked at a series of
simple substrates you can see here with
a simple cyclohexane derivative the
small oxidant TF do preferentially
oxidizes the sterically hindered but
most electronics tertiary site and nine
to one iron PDP he doesn't know what to
do because now it has a very sterically
hindered electron rich site but much
more sterically accessible less electron
rich site so it gives unselective
reactivity
however CF 3 PP now gives high
selectivity for the less sterically
hindered site notice your overturning
the site selectivity of the small tfeo
oxidant completely we look now at the
small polyketide fragment and what you
can see here is again and tertiary site
that is sterically hindered the iron PP
gives a mixture of products CF 3 PP now
takes oxidation and selectively oxidizes
the less sterically hindered methylene
site with respect to again this small
peptide fragment what we observe is
terse to the tertiary site is the most
electron rich but also sterically
hindered iron PP again is split it
doesn't really know what factor to wait
and so you get mixtures of oxidized
products CF 3 PP waste erics much more
heavily and so now you get selectivity 4
to 1 for oxidizing at the secondary site
so what this does now is it takes
reactions that are unselected with PP
because sterics and electronics are
moving in different directions and ways
sterics much more heavily making
Skerritt to the selectivity determining
factor however in cases where you have
tertiary sites that are pretty
sterically accessible CF 3 PP is still
able to
selectivity so here you can see a case
where this tertiary site is selected for
by iron canoe because it's electron rich
and pretty sterically accessible
two-to-one selectivity ca3 PP now
diverts oxidation away from this
relatively sterically expose site to the
methylene site so now you're able to
overturn the site selectivity of iron
PEP oxidations from two to one favoring
tertiary to two to one favoring the
secondary the same is true for a cyclic
molecules in this simple simple amino
acid derivative we see iron PP selects
for this relatively spherically exposed
tertiary site electron rich tertiary
site to the one CF 3 PP now turns this
over four to one selecting for the
methylene site we were in a very
privileged position now where we have
two catalysts that are waiting the
different physical organic properties of
c CH bonds and complex molecules in
different ways and so we felt that if
everything I'm telling you now is
correct you should be able to develop a
quantitative predictive reactivity
molecule model that will allow us to now
correlate the physical organic
properties of Ch bonds to the
empirically observed site selectivity as
a function of the catalyst and ideally
this quantitative models would both be
able to explain the selectivities that
we're observing but also to be able to
predict cell activities in molecules
that we haven't yet oxidized so let me
describe for you briefly this
selectivity model model the first thing
that we did is we developed a site
filter and this was based on
parameterizing the electronic and steric
properties of the CH bonds the
electronic properties are simply the NP
a partial atomic charges and these are
rank ordered the rank ordered in a
random way but it's being done and
systematically throughout all the
molecules that we've put into this model
with respect to sterics what we do is we
first evaluate the local steric so what
is covalently bound to the CH bond and
we simplify the different types of
things that are bound for example here a
mech
is converted into an ethyl a quaternary
Center is converted into a t-butyl and
these are evaluated as a values then we
sum this to the through space effects
such as axial 1 3 interactions eclipsing
interactions and some B's and in any
places where we feel that by doing the
oxidation we can alleviate ring strain
and take 20% of the a value and subtract
it from the total and this gives us now
sorry about this this gives us now the
steric parameters which we again rank
order in a random way that
systematically for all the molecules
that have been inputted into into this
model and so with this we are able to
get two equations out and I'm going to
sort of skip exactly how how we do this
but these are the two equations that
describe the iron PP oxidations and the
iron CF 3 P DP oxidations
and what you can see here through this
graphical depiction of these equations
is that just as we've been saying all
along
iron PP works best when there's a big
difference in electronics and a big
difference in sterics between the site
where CF 3 PP is very highly sensitive
and literally correlated to differences
in sterics between the two sites and so
now if we simply take the observed site
selectivities and plot them against the
calculated site selectivity is very
gratifying Lisi linear correlations and
this provides I believe the strongest
evidence that really this statement is
not accurate that there is in fact
measurable differences between the
physical organic properties Exige bonds
particularly in complex molecules and if
you have catalysts that can sense these
differences and exploit them and can
achieve predictable and separative site
selectively seat oxidation without
directing groups moreover you can devise
catalysts that can select for one of
these properties await them more heavily
than others and now you can turn over
selectivities with a small molecule
catalyst again without a directing group
let's look here
really at some case studies try Callie
alive he was the first molecule that we
evaluated and here you can see that
calculate that iron PP is going to give
us no selectivity between c6 and c7 you
look at the crude data you can
understand why this is c6 is not favored
electronically in almost any case and c7
or c6 is favored in almost all cases
sterically so with iron PEP oxidation
you can imagine it doesn't know what to
do electronics and stairs again
diverting I repeat the weights those
factors pretty equally what we observe
is again no selectivity between c6 and
c7 and also very poor mass balance here
for this oxidation most likely because
of off-site oxidation at c11 c12 would
see f3 PDP sterics is strongly favoring
c6 you can see from the crew data and
you calculate eleven to one selectivity
for c6 she's very consistent with what
we observe greater than ten to one
selectivity and interesting installation
of mass balance most likely because
these other sites that are
electronically now preferred or being
shut down because there's sterically
inaccessible to CF group EP artemisinin
we originally thought had many sites of
oxidation possible until we developed
this quantitative model run it through
our parameterised site photo we see that
it really comes down to two sites to c9
and c10 c 10 which is electronically
strongly favored and c9 hysterically
strongly favored so with this we observe
a ratio of 2 to 1 and calculate a ratio
of 1 to 1 again iron PP is conflicted
however you can see here that we're
getting very good yield of oxidized
products of c10 this is something that
this model really highlighted for us and
highlighted for us that in cases where
you know you have all the other sites in
a complex molecule being shut down and
it comes down to just two sites of
oxidation that you can get very good
yield even if you have very modest
selectivities here you can see like
products and sterics are strongly
opposing each other and so now in this
case it's a really good challenge for CF
3pp you've never had a case where
electronics was strongly favoring a
different site we calculate 17 to one
ratio we observe an eleven to one ratio
252 now % isolated yield of c9 oxidation
the last case is perhaps the most
challenging neck trial because now we
have many possible sites of oxidation
that all must all pass through the site
filter so we have now six sites that
remain you can see that in all cases c11
is electronically preferred however
there are many other sites that are
sterically preferred including c11 we go
ahead and just choose to look at C 11 C
10 and 12 and this word another aspect
that made this very very challenging was
the fact that no experimental data for
nectar al is inputted into our
reactivity model and so this is going to
be a true prediction again these two
factors electronics and sterics are
strongly opposing each other and so we
predict that you're going to get no
selectivity based on our model with iron
feet we observe effectively no
selectivity with cf3 PDP we predict a
three to one ratio
favoring the less sterically hundred
side of oxidation we observe in fact a
six to one ratio so now I want to just
switch gears one more time and talk to
you about a program and see each
amination so nitrogen as many of you
know is ubiquitous both in natural
products and pharmaceuticals nature like
organic chemists usually does not use CH
emanation to install nitrogen in fact it
uses functional group transformations
however very early on Breslin yelman
recognized the stereo electronic nature
of iron oxes and iron nitrenes and they
showed the first example of a siege
emanation going through a night screen
and immediate using both iron porphyrin
as well as for the first time Rodian
acetate this iron porphyrin result
remained dormant in literature for
nearly 30 years and as you know a lot
has come out
of noble metal exploration of rhodium we
decided to reexamine the iron case with
hopes again that using an iron nitrene
we could overcome this reactivity
selectivity paradigm that we had
observed that has been observed with
other types of metals such as rhodium so
we first decided to look at the allylic
amination of internal olefins and the
reason for this is there was no reaction
to do this in the literature when we
started noble metal catalysis such as
our palladium catalyst selects very
strongly for terminal olefins and does
not touch internal olefins the rhodium
nitrene catalysis has significant chemo
selectivity problems with the olefins so
we considered this chemo selectivity
issue and considered mechanistically
rhodium this point through a concerted
pathway for CH insertion you can see
here that it zero donation would also
have a concerted pathway that
electronically would not be very
different than the insertion pathway and
we believe energetically would be very
similar however now consider a iron
nitrene potentially this would be going
through a stepwise pathway similar to
our iron oxide chemistry and the
intermediate for now CH amination be an
allylic radical versus a secondary
unstabilized radical for the isère
donation process so based on this and
discovered the first iron needed
synthetically useful cinq amination
reaction that proceeds with now this
iron phthalocyanine catalyst a bulk
commodity reagent that is used to make
tires and also ink you can see here it's
widely applicable to a wide range of
different types of olefins with
excellent in all cases selectivity for
insertion over is irradiation this
reaction very similar to our iron off so
is very sensitive to electronics it
refers to an eight at the more electron
rich allylic site it's also sensitive to
Skerritt referring to emanate at the
more sterically exposed a low excite
this reaction however does not sort of
overcome the selectivity reactivity
paradigm it's very selective for
like emanations however it's not very
reactive and so we need in all cases a
turn element with the iron to get good
reactivity with these activated types of
bonds including the allylic and will
remove to unactivated bonds even these
tertiary bond with the turn element we
get very poor types of the activity you
can see here that we get complete stereo
retention just as we did with the iron
so unfold moving forward was could we
develop a catalyst that would be more
reactive that could address some of
these tougher barn types and tougher
substrate but still maintain chemo
selectivity and so in thinking about
this we thought about the mechanism by
which in fact this is happening and we
thought well rhodium you know is highly
reactive in his going for a concerted
mechanism whose iron is stepwise and
it's more chemo selective but less
reactive
perhaps because we're forming now a
unstabilized in a radical intermediate
so can we achieve something in between
by making the reaction left stepwise and
more concerted and in thinking about
this we thought about the nature of the
the metal nitrene and thought about well
could we achieve a metal nitrene that
was more Nitra noid in character and
thinking about the Aqsa pema street was
known that when you switch from iron to
manganese that in fact to make the the
Aqsa more ox annoyed as evidenced by the
fact that kinetic isotope effect is
smaller for manganese than it is for the
iron and so we simply did this we took
all the different types of catalysts
that we had the frameworks and we
switched out iron for manganese and you
can see something pretty striking which
is in all cases manganese is more
reactive and once again the fellow
signing wins out significantly in fact
over the original porphyrins that had
been examined and see the poor currents
are pretty unreactive we attribute this
to the very strong PI accepting ability
of phallus I means relative to
porphyrins making them perhaps more
electrophilic and more reactive
emanation of catalyst the addition of
molecular sips now improves the
reactivity
significantly by removing water but
really what makes the biggest difference
in this reaction is a change in the
catalyst structure essentially going to
this tert-butyl fellow signing catalyst
with this now we get significant Houston
reactivity for the tertiary but as
you'll see the boost in reactivity that
we see for other bond types is is really
remarkable so now let's look at the
scope of this reaction unsurprisingly
it's very good for tertiary emanations
based on our art so on our screaming
substrate you would have expected this
but now you push this and said let's
we'll look at secondary substrate and
you can see here now a real difference
between the manganese simple fellow
finding the tert-butyl fallow signing
with respect to reactivity growth
significantly more reactive than iron
but now the manganese tert-butyl phallus
I mean achieving synthetically useful
reactivity for secondary CH bonds and
you can see this range is a wide range
of secondary CH bonds there is a
preference for forming the six-membered
heterocycle geometrically however if
you're competing against a very strong
bond type such as a cyclopropane you are
geometrically able to form the five
membered ring in good yield so now
instead okay let's try to push this
reaction again further let's look at
something that really most metal
nitrates can't do which is primary c2
emanations in fact with Nitra noise
there's only been rhodium nitrates
there's only really been one example of
this in the literature a very very low
yielding example remarkably you can see
here again with the manganese Torpedo
fellow slimy now very good reactivity
for primary CH bond and the nation's and
you can see here in a substrate where
there is the possibility for doing a
secondary CH bond amination
you see that the geometric preference to
form the six membered ring now gives you
primary CH bond selectivity
unsurprisingly this reaction is also
very good for bends ility terminations
and what I would point out here
predominantly is the tolerance of this
reaction despite being so reactive to a
wide range of different medicinally
interesting how to recycle
now what I would say was very surprising
to us was the next result so we expected
based on this very high reactivity that
we would see essentially no selectivity
or diminished selectivity for allylic
emanations versus the observed nation
process I think pretty remarkably what
we observe is absolutely no diminishment
in the insertion to reservation ratio
across all these different bond types we
see the exact same very high keno
selectivity that we would see that the
original iron catalyst and the
selectivity and the reactivity exceeds
that of the iron and other catalysts
that have been developed specifically
for the purposes of the Akeno
selectively we next further challenged
the system by looking at Coburg Dilek
emanation something that is not possible
with so family derived my trees because
of competing reactivity with the probe
Argyl excite once again we see excellent
chemo selectivity for insertion into the
probe our village's each bond typically
these types of structures are formed
from these Hemi animals which obviously
we can also access and very good yield
and diastereomers all of these
principles of chemo selectivity and
reactivity hold up in complex molecules
you can see here very nice allylic
amination sigma sterile of the sigma
sterile derivative you can also see here
secondary CH emanation of isis tvl and
really remarkable yields five mill
percent catalyst loading uncut the
catalyst loading down to very low levels
and do this on large scaled these header
cycles are known to be able to be easily
derivatized so you can do that both with
nitrogen and oxygen to give precursors
of diamine or amino alcohol types of
motifs I think very remarkably you can
again do this on primary siege bonds in
complex molecule settings so in this
batch oolitic acid derivative we again
have a competition between now a
secondary site and a primary site go for
the more geometrically accessible six
membered ring functionalizing at the
primary position
76% yield one we do isomer one
stereoisomer sequential oxidations are a
very interesting thing
consider now all the molecules I'd shown
you previously had alcohol in them
naturally however you can think about
installing an off alcohol with our iron
PEP oxidation we can do sequential
observations only on ser electronically
activated substrate is generally want to
install an oxygen it shuts down further
observations but Mysterio electronically
activated substrates where there are
many possible sites of oxidation you can
use scary electronics to direct the
first oxidation to going from an
peroxide to square you lied and then
here use the combination of electronics
carrots and stare electronics with iron
PEP to now get very good yield of two ox
of stereo light oxidation you can now
use this iron PEP oxidation to install
your hydroxyl group which now you can
append your soul family tether to and
now once again here's a striking example
of the preference of the system to
undergo primary CH oxidation versus
other oxidation types in in these
complex molecules where Jim metrics is
playing a strong role so here you can
see that we've got two possible
alternate sites of tertiary bond now in
a secondary bond that would form the
five-membered heterocycle the Magana we
prefer to go with the primary Siege bond
which were formed the geometrically
preferred six membered ring hetero cycle
84% isolated yield i'm briefly just
going to talk to you about the mechanism
here remember our hypothesis was that we
had a metal bound oxidant that was
controlling both the CH cleavage and the
rebound step and also that this metal
Nitra nor that we were generating was
somewhere in between iron and rhodium
mechanistically so you can see here when
we examine the CH cleavage step that in
fact we looked at the intra molecular
kinetic isotope effects just as you
would predict the manganese catalyst
falls somewhere in terms of kie the tool
concerted rhodium and stepwise iron the
same with the Hammett studies you can
see here that the manganese kettles fall
in between the rhodium which is
concerted and doesn't have much of a
positive charge
build up in the transition state and the
iron which is more stepwise you're
forming a more pronounced partial
positive in the transition state with
respect to the rebound again
you can see that the radical rebound is
metal mediated and is very rapid so once
again we see concerted CH emanation with
both manganese paddles just as we did
with the iron however just as you would
expect with a non concerted reaction in
the case of a z allylic or contamination
you see some deterioration in the ZD
selectivity with both manganese and iron
four rhodium which is concerted you see
absolutely no erosion in that
selectivity finally looking at the
reaction kinetics what we observe is in
fact that the overall reaction profile
indicates that the manganese
phthalocyanine is more rapid than the
simple phallus I mean and much more
rapid than the iron phthalocyanine and
when we investigated whether or not the
manganese catalyst was involved in the
rate determining step it appears to be a
doubling of the catalyst concentration
needs leads to roughly a doubling and
the reaction rate of this reaction so
unlike the rhodium catalyst or the
rhodium is not involved in the rate
determining step here we have a
different kind of scenario so finally we
wanted to ask the question is the
manganese in bbc2 cleavage involved in
the rate determining step of this
reaction you can see that both parallel
reaction kinetics looking at the initial
rates and intermolecular competitions
indicate a kie of slightly above one so
this indicates that CH cleavage is part
of the rate determining step but does
not completely control the rate of this
reaction alright so with this at hand
and started off by trying to develop a
catalyst that is new moves more towards
reactive and maintain some chemo
selectivity falls somewhere between iron
and rhodium however once again what we
created was an outlier with this first
growth transition metal a catalyst that
is much more reactive than the known
noble metal catalyst
however maintain the excellent chemo
selectivity of the iron
I should also mention that this panelist
is much more abundant than rhodium ten
billion times more abundant and finally
this catalyst will be available from
Aldrich we have a product number and it
should be available in the fall of this
year so with that I'd like to just
conclude by saying that hopefully I
convinced you that not all CH bonds are
equal and this is particularly true in
complex molecule settings that with the
catalyst that is both reactive and very
sensitive to the physical organic
properties of seeds bonds you can
achieve catalyst controlled flight
selectivity that is tunable and with
this finally that seed bonds can be
considered a new type of functionality
in streamlining complex molecule
synthesis with this I just like to end
by thanking our funding sources in
particular the NIH which funds both of
these programs very generously and I'd
like to thank my group I try to show the
pictures I've gone along really this is
then the best part of working on very
challenging problem has been being able
to assemble a team of very highly
talented people to work on it with so
with this I'd like to take any any
questions that we have now Thanks thank
you very much professor white for a
fascinating presentation I think we all
enjoyed it very much we have a couple of
comments caring from University of
Florida saying thank you for the great
talk it's very very useful material we
had another comment from venkata at
University of Texas say Mary Musa
a great talk so I think we have a very
satisfied audience out there I find it
fascinating that knew some of it
the concepts that you presented were
very groundbreaking so I would like to
thank you for for that we don't have
very much time at all so I suggest that
if there are any questions if you could
send them over using the Q&A at 2:00
that you will find on your your system
please do submit them by a via via their
and and then with a Christina will be
able to to answer them and over the next
few few minutes I just want to remind
you all that there will be more talks
beginning at four o'clock and and you
can actually also see this presentation
again on on the magnet at the end of
December you can find the full program
on the agenda page and you can also have
the opportunity to go and visit their
virtual exhibit hall so thank you very
much it will be ready for tyranny and
especially to Professor white for a
fantastic presentation as I said if you
have any further questions please do
send them over and we will ask her to
stay around for a few minutes and answer
them without without any any further
comments thank you very much and thank
you for for being there